Why did you bring me to this place, but it's been more than half a year since Sekarin died in
the accident?  It's an easy time,
so let's check it out It seems
like I won't be satisfied if I don't do this The dance of the sacred shrine maiden
Miqo'te magic The next time is the coolest thing
Who do you want to impress?
What are you doing in the middle of the night?
Oh, you're a princess with one eye and one leg.
The fairies in the city are making noise.  Okay, is
that a mixture of Kudan and India?
You know that there was an accident
And that girl who disappeared in the 19th round What's
that girl?  At that time
tar
She didn't even try to exchange steel
Erg Shari That's like two books
If I had more stars I might have been stopped
You won't feel 7 u  By doing so, the
facts became clear, but the Japanese police are excellent.